my name is Jethro Sears I'm a member of
the engineering team for Microsoft teams
and education and as this demo I'm
actually going to show you how you can
use Microsoft teams to support your
research that you're currently doing
today so Microsoft teams is the hub for
teamwork for collaboration communication
but also a single glass of pane where
you can visualize all the applications
that you use in your process so let's
take a look what the features look like
and how you can use that to really make
your research more productive and more
efficient so what you see here is really
the interface of Microsoft teams and on
the left hand side you actually have a
number of buttons so this is a part of
the education set set up so you're going
to see there's some specific
functionality that is really assigned to
an education tenant so the first one is
your activity and this really gives you
an overview of all the tasks all the
information that you need to be aware of
if you're being tagged in a conversation
this is for example where you where it's
going to be appearing the second part is
really the first part of the
communication instant messaging it's
going to allow you to chat with your
team members but also with external
people so if you do research with
external people out of your university
you can actually use that here to start
that instant messaging for example here
you see how Meghan the person that I'm
logged into is actually having a
conversation with Nestor and Nestor can
actually communicate with Meghan both
through instant messaging but you can
see that they also can increase it to an
audio call and even a video call if they
need to they were work together on files
they can actually increase this with the
applications that they like to use the
next step that we're seeing is actually
the teams that we're a part of and if
you're a part of a university this could
be the research projects that you're
working on but also the classes that
you're a member of both as a teaching
assistant and maybe as a professor so
what you have here is really the
conversations in that specific teams the
files that are available that your work
on also notes think about OneNote this
is exactly what is available here you
can customize your team by clicking on
the plus so you can actually extend your
team with a number of applications that
we provide out of the box so here the
top you see all the Microsoft
applications going from a forum to
planner to even an integration with
github for example but we also have a
full integration with non Microsoft
applications and these are applications
created by software vendors certified
for Microsoft teams that you can use so
for example if you want to use Trello
for example or for meda
these are all applications that are
available you just click on it you
configure them and they're available for
you and your team here you have also the
meetings that you have available to
yourself so here's where you can set up
all the meetings you can actually do
online conversations you can actually
bring in external people here as well
what is really cool is that we have a
number of features specifically to the
meeting experience that you can use in
your research
think about a whiteboard think about
note-taking think about specific
applications assigned to the meeting
that you can use here you can actually
start conversations into the meeting and
actually grow from there and add more
functionality to it I really want to go
back to our teams and see that you have
a number of sub sections in every single
team every subsection can be a phase in
your research for example we have here
the venture capital research so you see
that we have a general tap and when we
go in here you see that we have a full
threaded conversation so people who are
new to the team can actually come in
here and follow the conversation of
everything that has been going on
specifically around that research so you
don't have to bring them back from an
archive here's the part about the grant
process you have here the market
analysis so you can actually cut
systemize this whole structure to
accommodate for your specific research
you're in full control you can actually
make that available like I said you can
customize this so for example here we've
added a website called VC economic
system dashboard that immediately will
be loaded into teams so teams is here
that real single plane of glass that you
will have to view all the information
specifically for your research and
finally what I want to add to it is if
you don't have the applications that you
feel that you need you can actually
customize and create your own
applications
Microsoft teams has a development
engineering platform as well where you
can customize and create your own
applications to connect to the services
that you would like so teams here
specifically for research provides you
not just the communication and the
collaboration environment but it also
allows you to extend it with your
favorite applications and if you have
build your own applications for example
in SharePoint Online they can also be
natively integrated into teams
so here teams it's really that single
pane of glass that help for
collaboration and teamwork that you will
have as a researcher and that you need
to be more efficient as well